[Música]
cientos de tropas israelíes avanzan por
las calles de llenín
un poco más lejos el sonido de una
rápida sucesión de disparos mientras
salía humo del campo de refugiados
mientras Israel lanzaba otra incursión
militar en la ciudad en la cisjordania
ocupada la ciudad también fue atacada
con drones durante una de las mayores
incursiones en casi 20 años las
autoridades israelíes afirman haber
atacado un centro de mando de las
brigadas de llenín en lo que describen
como una operación antiterrorista
estamos golpeando el centro del
terrorismo con una gran fuerza quiero
subrayar que no tenemos una lucha con
los palestinos en realidad nuestra lucha
es con los apoderados de Irán en nuestra
región que son principalmente jamás y la
yihad islámica
jamás
en las primeras horas del lunes llenín
se transformó en una zona de combate con
intensos tiroteos entre militantes
palestinos y tropas israelíes
desplegadas en la zona drones
sobrevolaron la ciudad y su campo de
refugiados una zona densamente poblada
donde viven unas 14.000 personas varias
personas han muerto y decenas han
resultado heridas según el ministro de
sanidad palestino lo que está ocurriendo
en el campo de refugiados es una
auténtica guerra o ataques desde el
cielo dirigidos al campo cada vez que
conducimos entre 5 y 7 ambulancias
volvemos llenos de heridos los
enfrentamientos entre fuerzas israelíes
y palestinos han sido frecuentes en yina
en los últimos meses el ejército israelí
dirige regularmente incursiones
militares en la región bastión de grupos
armados palestinos en junio una
incursión del ejército en el campo de
refugiados mató a siete personas un
portavoz del presidente palestino
denunció la operación israelí como un
nuevo crimen de guerra y el enviado de
la ONU para Oriente medio declaró que
estaba hablando con todas las partes
para rebajar la violencia y garantizar
el acceso de la ayuda humanitaria